ja ich habe jetzt noch was er nicht 16
Jahre immer noch genau gleich viel Spaß
wie am Anfang also ja sollte man aber
ausprobieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich zum Sport Podcast des
österreichischen Bundesheers heute zu
Gast Boulder Europameister Nikolai
uschnik herzlich willkommen danke
Meisterschaft in München du bist
angeschlagen in diesen Wettkampf
gegangen und das dort im Boot dann alles
rausgeholt erzähl mal wie hast du diese
Moment erlebt was ist jetzt noch immer
immer
richtige emotional wenn ihr dazu denkt
also wie gesagt das war's mit Sicherheit
der größte Erfolg ist jetzt in meiner
Karriere und das war ja alles das Saison
Highlight wo alle drauf hingestellt
haben es war bis dort und
mit der Krone Infektion davor sich das
natürlich schon ein bisschen ja auf
meine Kräfte irgendwie ausgewirkt oder
so und aber auf meine Erwartungshaltung
um was vielleicht sogar gut im Endeffekt
dass ein bisschen lockere eingegangen
bin aber ja dass das dann im Endeffekt
alles so
hätte hätte man nicht gedacht natürlich
und das mit deinen jungen Jahren vor
allem für den Klettersport bist du noch
sehr sehr jung hast du damit auch
vielleicht die internationale Szene
überrascht
ja ist schwarze sorgen dass das lasse
die anderen zu beurteilen aber ich war
davor eben
ein Weltcup Finale habe jetzt dann die
zwei Mal den vierten Platz gehabt im
Weltcup war auf dem Halbfinale und so
weiter es hat immer bisschen was
gefaltet und wirklich zu klettern oder
wirklich zu Bienen oder so und es war
irgendwie so
der Gedanke da okay jetzt soll es dann
irgendwann einfach wirklich passen und
das war dann einfach die Zeit reif und
super dass das dann einfacher
funktioniert hat und seitdem
funktioniert da gehen wir ganz kurz
damit auch später im Verlauf des
Gesprächs alle auf der gleichen Seite
sind sozusagen die Disziplinen durch was
gibt es da im Klettern es ist ja nicht
einfach nur klettern sondern
verschiedenste Dinge die man machen
müsst und können müssen also es gibt
jetzt im 31 Disziplinen das ist das
Bouldern eben das Lied wo man mit und
Speed klettern was sie nicht
Schnelligkeit geht und jetzt für die
nächsten Olympischen Spiele gibt's immer
die Boulder Lied Kombination also sprich
ja Kombination aus die zwei Disziplinen
und das bietet dann eben separat dass es
werden dann zwar olympische Medaillen
Entscheidungen geben fürs Klettern die
gab es so im Tokio nicht den klettern
war zum aller ersten Mal olympisch in
Tokio da gab es einen bewerben nämlich
einen Kombination Bewerb und der war ja
eher unbeliebte unter den klettern oder
auf jeden Fall also das war glaube ich
für alle
riesengroße Umstellung auf einmal eben
alle drei Disziplinen trainieren zu
müssen vor allem da halt das Bild
klettern so anders ist als eben das
Bouldern oder das Lied das kann man halt
schon fast eher mit der Leichtathletik
irgendwo vergleichen und darum war das
halt alles andere als ideal und das ist
jetzt sicher großer Schritt in die
richtige Richtung immer noch nicht
perfekt aber es ist auf jeden Fall immer
schon deutlich besser dass das Bild
einfach getrennt wurde und ja
hoffentlich dann in LA zwar 28,3
Disziplinen das heißt jeder einzelne
einzelgewertet damit auch die
Spezialisten jeweils mit einem Chancen
haben ist das auch etwas wofür ihr
Athleten laut werden kannst wir wollen
das als Verband müsste das irgendwie
hinkriegen auf jeden Fall
ja die die Masse oder die Mehrheit der
Athleten ist sicher dafür dass man
einfach die drei eins-disziplinen als
als Entscheidung jetzt hernimmt und man
ist Kombinationen und so weiter einfach
beiseite legt das war halt das Beste für
ein Sport wahrscheinlicher einfach da
halt alles Niveau natürlich irgendwo
höher bleibt wenn sich wirklich
Spezialisten auf ihre Spezial
Disziplinen konzentrieren können und mit
zwei oder drei so ist sind doch hier war
Disziplinen trainieren müssen und ja
wird einiges leichter machen und ja wir
hoffen natürlich sehr dass das zwar auch
der 20er voll sein wird das olympische
waren trotzdem dieser Herausforderung
großartig ich glaube der Klettersport
hat gezeigt dass auf jeden Fall auf die
olympische Bühne gehört warum so lange
gedauert dass das gestern olympisch
wurde ja sehr gute Frage ich glaube dass
der Klettersport hat sich halt voll in
den letzten Jahren einfach extrem
schnell extrem gut weiterentwickelt also
sofort 10 Jahre oder so im Vergleich war
das vielleicht der Sportler den man noch
nicht wirklich so gekannt hat da in der
Gesellschaft und vielleicht sehr weniger
Leid gewusst habe was das eigentlich ist
oder so und das hat dann halt so einen
Boom gehabt irgendwie und in den letzten
Jahren merkt man einfach auch so viele
Leute gehen klettern gehen in die
boulderhallen Studenten keine Ahnung
also es ist einfach sehr sehr sehr
beliebt mittlerweile und das war sicher
irgendwo ausschlaggebend und glaubst du
dass durch die sportlichen Erfolge
dieser Boom ausgelöst ist oder
ermöglicht dass der Boom die sportlichen
Erfolge weil jetzt so viele Menschen
retten es hat davor natürlich sportliche
Erfolge geben und das ist glaube ich
einfacher dadurch mit Infrastrukturen
keine Ahnung nimmt man das
Kletterzentrum in Innsbruck her oder in
Graz das Blockhaus dann einfach super
kletterstädte aufgebaut worden oder so
und dadurch natürlich kommen dann
Amerika Leute und interessieren sich
dafür oder so aber die die Leistungen
waren vor fünf sechs Jahren die gleichen
wie sie jetzt fahren jetzt profitiert
ihr natürlich von diesen Möglichkeiten
das jetzt das Kletterzentrum in
Innsbruck angesprochen zu trainieren ist
der dort auch
und mehrfachen Weltmeister Jakob
Schubert kann man da was lernen was
abschauen profitiert man wenn man so top
Leute die ganze Gruppe ist natürlich top
besetzt auf die anderen die noch dabei
sind aber direkt bei den Männern kann
man davon einander profitieren auf jeden
Fall also das war für mich damals der
Hauptgrund da noch Innsbruck zu gehen
noch nachdem mit der Schule fertig waren
bin das war einfach eben um eben in
Innsbruck einfach bessere Kletterer um
sich herum zu haben von dem man lernen
kann in dem Fall immer der Jakob Anna
der besten überhaupt der jemals in dem
Sport und da ist junger Körper
hinzukommen und jeden Tag die
Möglichkeit haben mit ihm zu trainieren
und dann mit der anderen mit anderen in
der Gruppe zu trainieren das bringt
einfach weiter natürlich nicht nur was
das Klettern geht Motivation
ich glaube man profitiert sehr sehr
viele Jakob auch wenn ihr jungen danach
kommt und ihm ein bisschen Druck macht
und das sieht ja leider alles alleine
dominieren können ja auf jeden Fall also
ich glaube dass mir mehr Burschen uns
gegenseitig sehr gut also es gibt Sachen
wo er sich wo er besser ist besser bin
und so gleicht sich das super aus und
ich glaube das ist jetzt in den letzten
an oder zwei Jahren mir echt extrem gut
zum Trainieren und können und extrem
viel voneinander lernen können und das
macht uns natürlich bei der irgendwo
stärker
was ist eine große Stärke dass das
Symbol dann bei dir so gut funktioniert
derzeit also ich glaube dass
wahrscheinlich mal größte Stärke in
Polen die ist dass sie eigentlich ja
sehr gut Allrounder bin also ich habe
sehr wenig irgendwie Schwächen oder so
ich kann die meisten Sachen alle
ziemlich gut oder so ich bin jetzt
selten sehr abhängig von vom roten Bau
wie runde jetzt vielleicht geschraubt
wird oder so es muss jetzt nicht immer
sein dass mir alles voll Entgegenkommen
muss oder so das ist eben einer der
wichtigsten Faktoren dass man einfach
alle Elemente sehr gut beherrscht weil
es einfach nicht nur uns um die Kraft
geht es geht um Koordination und
Technikum Boulder lesen also das ist
sicher etwas wodurch ist sehr
profitieren wird und das ist auch
hochtaktisch ich war mal bei dem
Wettkampf habe dort moderiert von euch
in Innsbruck in der Koma Phase und ich
war fasziniert wie intensiv man dieses
lesen betreiben muss der Strecke man
konnte heraus man weiß nicht was man
jetzt klettern muss und muss eigentlich
schauen dass man so wenig versuchen am
besten gleich beim ersten Mal die die
Strecke löst kann man das trainieren
dieses diese Strecken lesen oder geht
das nur durch
versuchen ja man natürlich kann man das
trainieren also wir mal mit dem Team in
Innsbruck und generell haben wir sehr
viele sowie wettkampfsimulationen wo wir
genau das eigentlich trainieren wie geht
man da heran und sowas mental und wie
kann man Polar so schnell wie möglich
lesen und auf die richtige Lösungen
drauf kommen oder so und das ist halt
ein Wettkampf etwas worauf es eigentlich
drauf ankommt also oft kann sein dass
man den boulders wenn man mal was wie es
geht vielleicht auch er kommt aber im
Wettkampf finde vier oder fünf Minuten
einfach nicht drauf kommt und deswegen
schafft man nicht und das ist natürlich
gibt's Leute sonder vielleicht
talentiert da und dann sich leichter
oder so aber man kann es auf jeden Fall
hat trainieren und das ist sicher ja an
einer der wichtigsten Faktoren Sport und
so kann es eben auch passieren dass
wirklich die gute Leute teilweise
Weltmeister dann die nicht schaffen
[Musik]
was mich dort fasziniert aber auch zu
sehen die Typologie der Kletterer es
gibt die die
mutigen die einfach mal drauflos machen
aber dann vielleicht zwei drei Versuche
brauchen und die vorsichtigen die durch
Studierende Polizei vereint und man das
Gefühl hat die Zeit läuft davon was
macht er und dann gleich im ersten
anlaufen wo würdest du dich einordnen
mittlerweile dadurch dass sie einfach
auch schon mehr Erfahrung habe ein
bisschen und das war jetzt eben mein
zweiter Saison bei der Erwachsenen im
Weltcup bin jetzt sicher routiniert als
vom Jahr und dadurch glaube ich mache es
ja teilweise einfach schon viel besser
als letztes Jahr dass sie halt in
manchen bouldern ist es oft besser
vielleicht früher einzusteigen früher zu
versuchen und man wirklich von der
Bewegung zu lernen und weniger zu
überlegen oder so aber auf diese extrem
gut eben sich wirklich am Plan davor zu
überlegen und dann vielleicht im ersten
Versuch das glaubt zu ziehen und das
mache ich aber mittlerweile ganz gut und
eine Vergleich das mit letztem Jahr
dabei vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu
sehr Kamikaze und gleich mal hin und
nicht viel überlegt und einfach getan
was oft gut sein kann aber oft Verhalten
durch das dann halt da versuche oder so
also
ja das ist halt da ständiger Lernprozess
glaube den man da durchmacht das macht
auf jeden Fall für Zuschauer und
Zuschauerinnen den Sport spannender doch
super zum zum Konsumieren und das
füttert auch ein bisschen diesen Trend
wenn man auf eurer Instagram Seiten
schaut dann habt ihr alle zigtausende
wenn nicht 100.000 Follower meistens
auch aus dem asiatischen Raum ist das
dort auch seine große halb Sportart ja
auf jeden Fall also gerade den in Japan
ist das Klettern richtig groß
mittlerweile schon und vor allem
natürlich ja deswegen weil die Japaner
sicherlich die stärkste Nation sind im
Klettersport zur Zeit also gerade bei
der Herren ist es wirklich ihr wie viele
starke Athleten die haben also
eigentlich in jedem Weltcup Finale sind
mindestens zwei Japaner drin oder so von
von der sexy Finalisten und von denen ja
da werden wir noch die nächsten Jahre
sehr viele sehen Finale wie hast du die
Veränderungen nach deiner Goldmedaille
erlebt was hat sich alles verändert
womit hast du nicht gerechnet
also mit was ich nicht so gerechnet habe
beziehungsweise und was ja einfach nicht
gedacht habe oder und das denkt man
glaube ich ja nicht man denkt halt vor
allem man sportliche und so und es war
dann schon sehr viele
Medieninteresse und einfach sehr viel
Trubel längere Zeit lang und war danach
anstrengend mit der Zeit aber man das
nimmt man natürlich dann schon in Kauf
aber ja und das denkt man halt im vorhin
nicht das oder war das das
einzige Ziel war das sportliche und dann
das denkt man und von dem träumt man
irgendwo jahrelang davor und ja alles
was danach kommen ist war eigentlich
dann da totale
Überraschung also und das habe ich dann
das ist dann so kommen wie komme ich im
Endeffekt das weißt du dass man im
Endeffekt diese Erfolge auch wiederholen
kann dass du durch deine Goldmedaille
jetzt automatisch zum erweiterten
Favoritenkreis zählst bei
weltkapselmeisterschaften
Weltmeisterschaften ich glaube es ist
schon oft so dass
also das wird man dann natürlich auch im
Laufe der nächsten Wettkämpfe und
zweiter sehen wie es jetzt weitergeht
aber oft ist glaube ich schon so dass es
einmal vielleicht so ein bisschen Knopf
aufgehen muss und dann läuft's ein
bisschen auf die Art
und es war davor natürlich auch nicht
schlecht oder so aber es hat halt immer
dieses bisschen falsch um ganz oben zu
stehen und ich merke schon aber bei mir
dass das riesen Erleichterung war
einfach für mich weil das einfach jetzt
schon lange in meinem Kopf drinnen war
und das war wollte einfach unbedingt
diese Medaille holen oder diese
Goldmedaille holen und das hat einfach
hat mir selber einfach ein bisschen
Druck genommen den immer selber gemacht
habe und dadurch geht man dann halt da
vielleicht bisschen lockerer in den
nächsten weltkämpfe und das das kann
schon helfen damit alle Faktor ist auch
sehr sehr hoch also wenn man weiß man
muss jetzt darüber man hat noch einen
Griff für Medaille und dann geht sie
vielleicht nicht mehr aus deinem Kopf
cool zu bleiben nicht die Nerven
wegzuschmeißen wie trainierst du dass du
schaffst du das
Mentaltraining mit einem alten Trainer
von mir in Kärnten und ist auf jeden
Fall ist extrem wichtig glaube ich und
ich glaube dass sie dadurch schon sehr
viel profitieren habt können das war
halt früher wie das vielleicht nicht so
ernst genommen und hat man da habe ich
gute Nerven es geht schon irgendwie aber
wenn man dann halt irgendwie wirklich an
die an die Weltspitze will und dann
entscheidet sich dann halt vielleicht da
Apost und nicht oder erst im Kopf und
nicht an der Wand oder so und da kann
man glaube ich sehr viel außer holen und
dadurch macht pervers sind da dran zu
bleiben und da und dem zu arbeiten
natürlich
Mentaltraining gehört dazu was sind noch
Elemente die du trainieren musst um so
beim Form zu sein also ich trainiere
jetzt nehmen
spezifischen Klettertraining mache ja im
Olympiazentrum in Innsbruck immer wieder
was also
Ausgleichstraining für Problemzonen für
z.B meine Schulter woher Verletzung
gehabt habe oder eine Handgelenk also
einfach dass man da konstant schaut an
den Problemen irgendwo zu arbeiten dass
die einfach eben minimiert werden oder
im besten Fall gar nicht mehr vorkommen
und
jetzt zur Zeit ist zum Beispiel auf
Phase wo ich Konditionstraining sehr
viel mache Firmen in der Woche Radel
fahren laufen und so weiter einfach mal
gute Grundausdauer zu haben und besser
zu regenerieren und so weiter jetzt ist
es dadurch halt normal um einiges
intensiver geworden dadurch dass jetzt
zwei Disziplinen trainieren trainieren
und ja da muss man vielleicht noch ein
bisschen mehr investieren als davor ist
das auch üblich so viel Ausdauertraining
zu machen oder ist das etwas
Spezifisches oder sagst ich weiß ich
brauche das oder ich profitiere davon
deswegen mache ich das auch wenn die
Kletterwelt das eher nicht so oft
betreibt egal es ist ganz
unterschiedlich ich muss ehrlich sagen
ja bis jetzt eigentlich sehr wenig in
den Bereich getan weil in dieses Gefühl
gehabt habe das ist jetzt unbedingt
notwendig oder so aber natürlich haben
der Trainer vielleicht auch auf der
anderen Meinung dazu und dadurch ist das
mittlerweile schon so dass die meisten
an dem Bereich versorgen machen weil es
natürlich ja Sinn macht dann einfach um
besser in Form zu sein und besser zu
regenerieren zu können und so weiter und
ja ich glaube es kommen jährlich neue
vielleicht Ideen dazu neue Ansätze im
Training wo vielleicht man irgendwas
anderes macht und dadurch ist macht es
ja sehr interessant glaube ich und da
neue Sachen auszutesten und ja hoffen
dass die ja funktioniert
neue Sachen austesten kann man oft auch
am besten in der freien Natur aber die
Routen nicht ganz so vorgegeben sind
viele Kletterer sind dann auch im
Training oder im Ausgleich am Felsen
noch klettern wie siehst du das also ich
persönlicher bin sehr gerne am Selzer
also ich mache sehr viele felskletter
Trips und so weiter zum Beispiel jetzt
da demnächster 12 Tage im Tessin in der
Schweiz dann bald fahren wir wieder noch
Amerika zum Bouldern also ein bisschen
wenn diese saun erlaubt oder wenn er mal
Zeit ist wie es eigentlich jetzt zur
Zeit der ist bei mir dann bin ich sehr
gern draußen einfach weißer super
Abwechslung ist das super
Trainingseffekt und es macht vor allem
aber sehr viel Spaß aber kann man das
dann auch wirklich als als Training
rechnen ähm steht einem Plan zwei Wochen
fällt der Training oder ist das einfach
man hat einen Effekt immer mitnimmt aber
im Endeffekt ist es gerade na es ist
schon also es ist vielleicht ein
bisschen
Thema für für Wettkampf Kletterer es
gibt manche die sagen okay sie
profitieren da nichts und ihnen bringt
das nichts und sie wollen das ja dann
ganz klar nicht und machen sie nicht
aber es gibt sehr viele und das ist
wahrscheinlicher die Mehrheit die sagen
es bringt Ihnen sehr wohl was und die
machen es dann auch und dann kann man
das auch ganz normales trainingsegen
also bei mir ist jetzt im Trainingsplan
sah meine trainingspasen ganz klar
abgestimmt und die andere Trainingsphase
passt zwei Wochen falls oder so und man
trainiert halt einfach ein Prinzip ist
es sehr gutes Training einfach weil man
dann fällt
sehr viel kleine Griff hat das ist zum
Beispiel für die Fingerkraft äh sehr
gutes Training für die Maximalkraft
schwere Sachen probieren also wie gesagt
es gibt glaube Leute die sagen da ist
nichts von mir und dann gibt's wiederum
Leute die sagen es bringt sehr wohl was
und die machen es dann halt automatisch
gern der Ursprung des Gitter natürlich
auch von dort die Simulation das
Wettkampf in der Halle ist ja dann im
Endeffekt das was das ganze eigenes
jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen dass das
Fels klettert auch eine Spur
gefährlicher ist als das wandklettern ja
das meint man immer aber man muss
unterscheiden zwischen zwischen
wirklicher Sportklettern am Fels ob es
jetzt das Bouldern ist ob es jetzt oder
gesagt hat dann man ist halt immer
gesichert am Fels hat man immer beim
offensichtlich und ist immer
abgesicherten beim Polen hat man die
Matten drunter und ja Leute glaube ich
meinen oft automatisch mit face klettern
irgendwie Bergsteigen oder alpine
klettern und das muss man wiederum halt
unterscheiden weil das was wir machen am
Fell ist ist keinerlei gefährlich was
war die schönste Landschaft in der du
schon komplett anders schwer
abends auszusuchen aber jetzt sehr gut
gefallen nein in Norwegen vor zwei
Jahren ein Flattern richtig gut gefallen
oder ein in Red Rocks in Nevada ist
immer sehr interessant immer zu reißen
als Kletterer und neue felsgebiete zu
sehen und dort zu klettern und einfach
nur Eindrücke zu kriegen und das ist
sicher cooler und Faktor den man da
erleben darf was immer so naturgezogen
ist das auch ein Grund warum
ja auf jeden Fall also man ich bin vom
vom Land und war natürlich als Kind sehr
viel draußen aber andere Sportart
gemacht oder so und wieder eigentlich
zum Klettern kommen bin war eigentlich
unabhängig davon das war bislang andere
Geschichte hat dann eben anfangen so
Kletterkurse zu geben in meinen
Heimatort wo eigentlich davor Skifahren
war und dann sie eben gesagt haben sie
machen jetzt da klettersektion auf und
so bin ich dann eigentlich erst zum
Klettern kommen und meine ersten Jahre
war er war halt da durch meinen ersten
Trainer eigentlich vor allem sehr viel
am Fell ist also das war für mich meiner
in meiner Kindheit sehr wichtig und das
ist mir so irgendwie beigebracht worden
und drum glaube ich ist es halt ja jetzt
immer noch so
warum war für dich klar okay das ist es
das ist meine Sportart ich war seine die
habe nämlich wohl angefangen habe zum
Klettern aber noch Fußball gespielt da
schick waren da an dem natürlich auch
viel Spaß gehabt oder so beim Klettern
war eigentlich von Anfang an irgendwie
klar okay na passt es das ist es und
wenn ihr mir jetzt so probiert Ruck zu
erinnern hat's dann nie irgendwie so
Überlegung oder vergeben das war einfach
von Anfang an für mich klar dass ist das
was sie tun würde und das würde jetzt
nicht leid tun sondern das da möchte die
allerbesten der Welt werden Saft ja
bedeutet was das für Applikationen für
deine Lebensentscheidungen hat für
deinen Berufsalltag immer in dem Alter
wie das noch nicht gewusst nach aber
also wenn jetzt druckt denkt wo ich
schon vielleicht ein bisschen älter war
oder so natürlich macht man sich dann
irgendwann Gedanken was macht man
vielleicht da abseits vom Sport oder so
aber es war trotzdem irgendwie immer in
meinem Kopf klar okay das ist mein Ziel
und das will ich machen und das wäre ja
laufen irgendwo und darum habe ich auch
selten jetzt irgendwie wirklich Zweifel
gehabt und mir gedacht mal vielleicht
taugt man doch nicht oder vielleicht
will dir doch was anderes machen als er
war eigentlich von Anfang an immer sehr
entschlossen mit der Zweifel kommt man
noch nicht so weit weiter soll es
natürlich auch gehen die Olympischen
Spiele in Paris da stehen natürlich an
wie schaut da die Qualifikation aus wie
schaut da deine Zielsetzung aus Paris
ist natürlich jetzt derzeit das größte
Ziel für mich
das ist ja dass er was jetzt trainiert
das ist der Grund warum jetzt das Lied
davor allem mit trainieren und wenn das
nicht auf die polasse Song konzentrieren
ähm darum natürlich muss man da bereits
ein bisschen was zu opfern aber da
olympische Traum ist dann doch größer
als alles andere und deswegen ist das
hat sicher meine größte Ziel zur Zeit
und die Qualifikation wird sicher nicht
leicht das qualifizieren sich halt
wieder nur 20 Lite boah
Männer und Frauen und ja es wird sehr
schwer werden es wird Heia auch schon
mal richtig hartes Jahr
badedisziplinen eben mal zu starten aber
es ist auf jeden Fall realistische
Chancen und hier draußen mal zu und ja
auf das Arbeiten und dann geht es darum
weltraumliste und Platzierungen und
Punkte und Quali Wettkämpfe was was
musst du konkret schaffen damit das also
es gibt eben Quali Events eigentlich die
erste Möglichkeit ist nächstes Jahr bei
der Weltmeisterschaft der qualifizieren
sich die Top 3 aus der Lied Kombi dann
gibt's ja noch
European Qualifier Event in Frankreich
glaube ich der qualifiziert sich der
beste Europäer von den noch nicht
qualifizierten und im Frühjahr zwar 24
sind dann eben noch einmal
wahrscheinlich drei Events oder so was
ich dann halt die restlichen
qualifizieren können und um dort
überhaupt hinzukommen musst du leben
haben jetzt kommen Saison über die
Weltcups
qualifizieren also was gar nicht genau
das steht glaube ich auch noch nicht
ganz fest aber wahrscheinlich Top 50
oder so und die kommen dann zu die Quali
Events und da geht's dann halt um die
Wurst kann man auch sagen wer sich
qualifiziert hat ist im Endeffekt aus
diesen 20 Leuten Medaillenkandidaten
also
jeder der sich für die Olympischen
Spiele qualifiziert wird
realistische Chance haben
und man hat seinen Docs oder was noch
ein bisschen anders da mit der alten
Kombination aber vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr Zufall auch noch oft drinnen
dadurch dass das Bild halt sehr viel
verändert hat oft dann für die nichts
Speed Kletterer das macht jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen besser das ja
vielleicht einfach ein bisschen weniger
Glücksfaktor oder so wird ist aber ja
Verständnis als Speed da muss man im
Endeffekt die Handgriffe auswendig
können und du musst alles passend
weil es kann man wie gesagt mit mit
einem Sprint vergleichen in der
Leichtathletik es ist immer die gleiche
Route die es zu klettern gibt und da ist
mittlerweile auch der Weltrekord schon
bei 50 also eV verrückt wenn man darüber
nachdenkt und da haben halt die nicht
Spee Tabletten natürlich kann es Chancen
und darum was sehr viel Zufall weil dann
rutscht da einmal weg der andere den
besten Lauf seines Lebens und da hat man
auch schwer sagen keinen Wert von dir
nichts bietet hätten wird jetzt der
beste Speaker sein das war auf jeden
Fall
spannend zum Zuschauen und natürlich
sportlich äh schwierig für euch das sagt
du musst jetzt Lieder sind verstehen mit
trainieren wo ist da der Unterschied für
dich im Training musst du viel mehr Zeit
dafür aufwenden oder ist einfach
grundsätzlich etwas ganz anderes zum
Trainieren ja es ist natürlich schon was
anderes also
einerseits ist das Boulder Training gut
für das Lied Training das Lied Training
ist aber gut fürs Boulder Training aber
wenn man es mit einer gewissen
Intensität macht dann kommt man sich da
oft vielleicht in den Weg und das ist
recht schwierig das abzustimmen dass man
es wirklich beides gut trainiert aber
dann auch nicht schwächer wird in seiner
Hauptdisziplin oder so also für mich ist
jetzt halt das Ziel im Lied aber das
Grundniveau aufzubauen aber halt
trotzdem zugleich zu schauen dass sie
mein Polder natürlich in Polen meine
Form Halt und dann nicht schwächer wird
und das ist relativ kompliziert und da
glaube ich schwieriger im Training zu
vereinbaren aber ja für das haben wir
die Trainer und dann mit der Arbeit
sehr fest daran dass das passt deswegen
gibst du tagtägliche alles kommen wir
zum Abschluss seiner kleinen Frage Runde
für dich nicht dass wir bis jetzt nicht
schon Frage Runden hatten das
begeisterte an dich an deinem Sport am
meisten wahrscheinlich die Vielfalt dass
er jedes Mal wenn man
ich habe dein Geld macht man eigentlich
was neues ob es jetzt in der Halle ist
oder am Fels man hat so viele
Abwechslungen man kommt so viel herum
man sieht so viel werden so viel Leute
erkennen also der ganze Lifestyle ist
eigentlich extrem cool für mich und ja
ich habe jetzt noch was er nicht 16
Jahre immer noch genau gleich viel Spaß
wie am Anfang also ja sollte man aber
ausprobieren also sein als Kind wollte
ich zuerst Bürgermeister werden und dann
Weltmeister im Klettern Weltmeister dann
Bürgermeister ist super Reihenfolge
kann ja noch werden meine stärkste
Eigenschaft ich glaube dass sie sehr
entschlossen bin mein unnützes Talent
sie mir sehr gut
ähnlich von Fußballspielern merke
das wäre super weil Sport Kommentator
ich träume
Olympischen Spielen schöner Traum und
deshalb auch in Erfüllung gehen alles
Gute nikolauschnik danke
fürs dabei sein ich freue mich auf euch
beim nächsten Mal
[Applaus]